thank you very much so a little bit of a
back my background I used to be a quant
for hedge funds and investment bank for
almost 20 years and everything ended
with Lehman Brothers and now I'm running
my own data analytics company with a few
products out there and I'm going to talk
about one of the most interesting probes
I work i did about 10 billion dollars
worth of these sort of deals that went
to the capital markets and these are
very exotic assets so monetizing data
basically securitisation of date so cut
catastrophic had borne it's a very it's
a highly structured form of a security
whose default is not triggered by a
credit event but by a natural or
man-made disaster and it doesn't have
any correlation with the stock market so
it's very attractive as a powerful a
portfolio because he helps the returns
of your portfolio to to this day there
are several types of this risk risk that
has been securitized some of them are
earthquake yuri kane weather with storms
there was a terrorist attack bond and
there are talks of our oil spill
satellite launches and or so the way
this works and I have to give this about
10 min you preview of this because this
is a complex topic and I'm going to put
a lot of cold out there so you need to
understand the mechanics otherwise you
doesn't make any sense I want to explain
a little bit of the background the
rationale for this sort of structure so
you understand the code i'm going to
show you so basically investment bankers
what i used to do we set up something
called SP week which is an offshore
entity that is creatively sole purpose
of ensuring somebody a corporation a
country this SPV they set up offshore
doesn't have any money so it is
bonds to the capital markets the balls
then are put in a collateral account to
wait for either the event happening the
earthquake the hurricane the catastrophe
or the maturity of the bond so the event
happens the insurer gets money or all or
part of the money if it doesn't happen
at the maturity of the bond of the bond
investor gets to money back and in the
meantime the the morning is selling an
account investing in triple-a securities
or US Treasuries so there are many type
of structures but we're going to talk
about the parametric because it's the
most transparent the most quantitatively
most data intensive so the parameters
the trigger the default of the bond are
all physical phenomenon that can be
measured that can be quantified but
there are some concerns because the
event may happen let's say the
earthquake and the losses are greater
than what the bone is going to pay or
the committee case that the earthquake
happens and there are no losses sorry
there is a windfall profit for the
insurer so it has many advantages of a
regular insurance because you know
everybody knows that when an insurance
you insurable event is triggered the
insurance companies usually have to
measure the claims observe and there is
a long development pew before any claim
is pay but I forgot to ask a question
how many of you work in finance or hedge
fund so I have an idea okay and physics
anybody or engineering okay so it's more
or less I preferred if we leave their
questions later because there is a lot
of stuff okay so we're going to be
seeing the calculation of a parametric
bonds is going to be in 30 minutes we're
going to try to do something that takes
usually three or four months of
calculations at least ten years ago so
there's a lot of information here
so a parametric bone the parameters are
observed of the magnitude the epicenter
and that at least two of these three
parameters and there are some
intermediate steps there has to be an
analysis a time series analysis of the
historical earthquakes selection of area
and calculation that is very important
call probability of survival which is
something border from credit derivatives
tell us a time installment temperatures
they have different types of parameters
to measure for example terrorist attack
is a mortality risk landmark damage
backstop limits so to understand how an
earthquake it compares to her type of
catastrophes I put together this chart
and it shows on the left in the left
side has scaled from two to ten then
it's just end-of-the-world scenario
earthquake but the equivalent millions
of pounds of opinions upon of TNT
release so you can see here for example
the Hiroshima atomic bomb is about the
same or what's about the same as a kobe
earthquake of 1995 and then we have the
chile earthquake of 919 60 which was 9.5
one of the oprah i think it's the
highest on record and the frequency of
earthquakes is on the center axis so you
see that this big earthquake happened
less than one a year once a year and the
other ones happen a lot more so let's
analyze this real deal and we are going
to try to replicate it in a different
part of the world so in 1998 Tokyo
Disneyland was trying to get insurance
against an earthquake happening in Tokyo
so they had they have exposure to
earthquake risk and at that moment that
we're looking for insurance from regular
insurers you know AIG is with reaming
agree all of those guys and the radial
charming was ten percent rate online
very simple you 100 million door
section you have to pay ten percent of
that in premium it's very expensive so
is there a solution in the capital
markets this is the firstborn of this
type that you know we issue once issue
which bypass insurance companies
completely so tokyo disneyland i set up
an SPV in the cayman island was set up
called concentric concept it doesn't
have any money so concentric issue bonds
to the market for one hundred million
dollars and the money was put in an
account waiting for again the event to
happen or the maturity of the bond so
this is what happens the issue on the
mount the issuance amount was one
hundred million dollars and obtained a
ba one rating from movies and B b-plus
from Standard & Poor's there's those are
equivalent ratings and the bone spur at
a time 303 point ten percent over libor
rate and this is basically the structure
which is very interesting because he
looks like a trailing dots on the ad
darb or so the latitude and longitude of
Tokyo Disney line is used as a reference
point and then the quants the structures
set these ratios of ten kilometers
around the Tokyo Disneyland then 50
kilometers and then 75 kilometers and
then we set up this sort of table that
says that if an earthquake of 6.5
happens and it's in the center then the
investors lose twenty five percent or 25
million dollars they then the whole
structure on wines and it ends the deal
ends and as you can see the scale bass
shop for earthquakes the payouts
increase dramatically for n quakes right
there because the damage is highly
correlated to losses in Tokyo Disneyland
right there but as you move away from
the center the losses the earthquakes
had to be very powerful to have an
effect in in the red dot
and that's basically the work of the
pond you know you have to work on these
moles until you find the right balance
and the rest an equation that relates
all of these to what the bond should pay
when or are we trash arbitrage setting
but it's very computer intensive I'm
doing it 10 years ago or 15 years ago in
C++ and a front end in Excel is just an
imer but you get it got done so I I'm
doing this in Python now and it's
amazing like a now where you can do a
million simulation so it used to take
three days for me on a cluster machines
do 100,000 simulations three days and i
will just non pi a million simulations
in few seconds so let's see some of the
code and how this works so here just
loading all the libraries the most
important its own pie and pandas my own
library and see pie stats the rest is
just for wanting stuff so here I just
this has been made this model very
generic you just type the name of the
city or country and it with little
information so here using this new
locator geko we find the the XY
coordinates of the Salvador and I had
there is a caveat here the information
are going to be analyzing in size of
2003 there is data from two thousand
three two now which is not public so I
cannot use that information so we are
going to step back in time and price
this one as to as of 2003 because I have
complete information 2003 to now yes I
could show you privately but this is a
public forum so we know it is not
so here this is going to get complicated
here scrolling these years yeah one I
guess I had to I cannot scroll this
because of the map the size of the map
so right here ok so let's forget about
the map isn't getting the way so i said
my start time of 911 1900 and the end
time is end of last year i'm going to
retrieve all this information from the
US Geological Survey but we're going to
do the analysis of 2003 so here we
connect using the request request Larry
to the US Geological Survey and we
request all this information we get the
information and i get rid of all this
data that we don't need to have a
cleaner and this little equation here
basically is going to calculate the
distance between the epicenters of
earthquakes and the city of san salvador
i chose the city of san salvador because
as an actual dealer was pitching to the
government of its oval or ten years ago
and it's in the Pacific is called the
Pacific Ring of Fire a lot of geological
activity and you should even this small
countries Latin American countries get
hit bad like a hurricane or an
earthquake the impact on GDP is twenty
thirty forty fifty percent of GDP and
sometimes in the small islands you can
see cases of one hundred percent of GDP
so these are huge that after you see
mine something happen here in this
country that has an impact of one
hundred percent of GDP that's horrible
sin of the world so the problem with
these deals is that they are very
quantitative and you had to pitch this
to decision-makers are usually not you
know programmers you know anything about
programming some in many cases but you
sometimes find very competent staff that
understands what you're doing and they
do and also
of these got done after 23 years of
basically education like meetings like
this once every three months to higher
and more senior more senior people over
time but they get done so looking at the
earthquake data rates from 100 years we
see that the max magnitude we have it's
a 7.8 earthquake so here I said my
circles just like in the concentric
circle Tokyo Disney line 50 100 150
kilometers around the center of the town
and and I'm going to plot and here I'm
going to see that top 10 so we see that
the top 10 the first one was a 919 02
7.8 magnitude that was the epicenter in
Chiapas Mexico and you see big
earthquakes here we compared to nuclear
explosion right so here I was playing
with this library called base map of
Mudd Club leave and I was able to create
this very cool chart that shows assume
or the city of el chalten salaries right
here and these are the circles i define
a ball when these black dots are the top
10 earthquakes in 100 years in the
database so we look here on the left on
the right side the distribution of that
and you can see as if air quake becomes
more intense stronger than the frequency
decreases here I found this very
interesting bulky library and we can
just plot look at the frequency of
earthquakes in the time series but in a
different from a different perspective
so basically we're going to be designing
a bond that cover the spikes these
spikes are the ones are causing problems
and are causing destruction remember
where quake scale is not linear is a
logarithmic scale so a serm from 22 from
1 to 2 is not twice it's 10 times
so here you start analyzing the
parameters so here's the distribution of
magnitude here's the distribution of
depth because not many people pay
attention to this parameter but it's
very important because you can have a
7.5 earthquake that is very shallow and
has totally different effect on the same
point file is 400 meters on the ground
so you want to protect against the
shallow ones but this is the things I
could not do 10 years ago because it was
difficult here i can see quickly a
couple of lines of code it looks like we
are not dealing with we want single
distribution but it almost looks like a
try mole distribution so three
distribution overlapping so we are going
to go and try to break it down into the
component distributions because we don't
have time for that but but you start
saying things that it was impossible to
see a few years ago same thing would add
it to and longitude so I like to use
this Larry call Seaborn because it
allows you there sunlight is allows you
to intersect distribution so what
happened with the distribution of
latitude longitude etc and now here we
can see that the Deb is concentrated
around 30 kilometers in that but here
this is very interesting this is a try
model thing that we saw in the histogram
the latitude looks like there are three
main focus of earthquakes this trip and
so actually you know I can actually tell
you what the center is and we can send a
geologist and find out what's going on
there maybe they should I was measuring
station right on top of that dot but
this is amazing what you can discover
when you start doing data science with
this sort of thing so this is a market
data in order to price the ball we need
to know what are similar bonds price at
and this is all the bones in the market
this is a head the top five as of 2003
and we have for example this one Cobra
see and sherry
that the hollow three-year term and the
lipase library plus five point seventy
six percent but when you read this
documentation because these are private
placements they give you two key
statistics one is corporal relative
first loss and expected loss Oprah
bility first losses what's the
probability as a name implies that the
investor is going to have one dollar
applause that's the priority first loss
an expected loss is when the last
happens was the average loss once you
have those two values you can plug them
into an equation that I work with some
guys a minute Ray and explains very well
the pricing of the bonds are going to
show that next discharge just the same
thing the same market but is showing the
amount of the bonds as bubbles so the
bigger bubble was a bigger bond issuance
than the smaller bubble and here this is
very interesting where we have here the
green and red line our corporate bonds
in the United States I have the same
rating as a cat bond so this is an
interesting we have something that are
equivalent in risk but the cat bond is
paying more to investor and this
happened because the market doesn't
really understand this bone they're very
quantitated know everyone has a Quadra
data science to analyze this because you
have to have a lot of expertise in many
areas so this sort of opportunities how
are out there so why would if you are
power bond money that can have BB bones
in your portfolio why would you buy one
corporate when you can buy this is
allowed you're allowed to buy it but it
has a you know three percent 300 basis
points pred pick up another thing that
we need to look at is their ratings by
the rating agencies so basically
awaiting a user's are telling you that
if you have something the has a
probability of one point four four
percent of happening then that thing
gets rated B b-plus so now we have
almost all the elements you know we need
to find out what's the probability of a
6.5 earthquake happen in this town
and we can start looking at some of the
things so this is the know the mole that
gives you the spread is this power power
law equation that you can agree the
factors to the market you can use I
skied learn one of those not no time to
do it here but I serve 2003 these are
the factors gangman alpha and bit which
are right here so now I'm going to go
back to my data frame of el salvador and
i'm going to capture the pfl and let's
say we want to protect the country
against earthquake of 6.5 so the
probability of 6.5 is 0.008 less than 1%
and it goes up when you go all the way
to 7.5 7.6 well the probability of that
happening is very small so now with this
we do a Monte Carlo simulation and this
is what this thing is amazing non pi
because you can do a mean simulations in
seconds and I'm gonna take the
parameters from 78 to 2003 so there are
some theories out there that said that
the frequency and the severity of
earthquakes is increasing so we take a
whole time series he may not be
representative of what's happening the
last 10 or 20 years so that's what I'm
limiting here to the last 25 as of that
date and then I do I calculate what's
the probability of 6.5 earthquake
happening and it turns out that there is
a probability of 1 even every 500 days
so we're going to do a hypothetical 1
billion dollar bond and we are going to
set up this table just like the
concentric deal in Japan so if 7.5
burster lose one hundred percent etc and
if you want to see that in a graphical
format it's the same thing here you know
so you just go here a six-point a
happening in the blue line which is the
circle it represents a fifty percent
loss or something like that so here we
do a meal simulations I simulate
latitude longitude magnitude and
distance and
this is the distribution of the
background of my simulator earthquakes
red versus the real earthquakes blue and
we can see that in the simulated we get
some earthquakes of magnitude 8 which
have not happened in real life so if we
plug all of these into here we just do
the calendar losses we blow all of that
we find out the loss for this bone
expected loss of a billion in 7.5
million is not that much we plug that
into the equation I show you before
spread over libor with the gang on the
Alpha that's spread so that bond we just
design a 1 billion dollar bond for a
sovereign country and I born back then
we'll have pay libor plus four percent
how to get this to reality it's a
different story because a lot of
regulation has to be in place you know
the Minister of Finance has to get ball
the president of the country has to
change regulations to gray SPVs it's a
whole internal process but I'm glad I
have the patient to war with these
people and I got to do some of these
yields so now and if anyone has
questions
it's a good question you know i don't i
don't know i know that guys like de show
and similar super quantitative
headphones aqr are using python and the
sort of libraries i think JP morgan is
also has an initiative to use these but
I don't think is widespread and there is
an Excel mentality still it's a very
close thing there is no version control
you know and and this is a very
sophisticated models but now that we
have on a Piton the bull with we just an
overload on you can put an eye python of
Buchan on one of these cloud things you
know you can start seeing a lot of I
think you can they want to start putting
the investment the technology and the
people banks can start issuing some
bonds of this nature generating new
business for their organizations because
it's a lot easier to structure one of
these with these tools that you know
with what with the closed system the
hughes now there was an article very
interesting a in november to lace ago
the senator john mccain said that there
is a 15 million shortfall amongst own
financial groups to cover extreme low
scenarios of catastrophic catastrophic
risk and it was referring to JP morgan
morgan stanley and goldman sachs so you
know all of all of these guys have
community operations and they have
offshore rigs and they are doing gold
mining and oil but if one of these
environmental disasters happens or one
of our nair quake or something the
losses are a lot more than whether
regulators are measuring right now so
there is now and you talk about how do
we turn mention this thing how do we
hedge this is very timely that you know
this came after you have put together i
hope pilot a presentation so i just
incorporated easy because is very timely
and this is just a few of the deals that
were doing with similar metal
youth is a very exotic risk but I got
involved in all of this and it's
fascinating me chris is a lot easier to
do in a less then 10 years ago just ten
years ago any question any other
question the regulator survey database
is a free access and they some of the
information for the bonds you can get it
from the specialized website called
Artemis dot BM in some publication that
just does cat bones and in space in
Bermuda but it's very difficult to get
beat and ask spreads usually when you
when the back celled is born the buyer
is one single buyer so get get hold of
the details of that private placing it's
very difficult what I have what I show
you how big a spread of all of those
bonds and likely the calibration because
we were trying to put a deal in 2003 or
you was in deutsche bank and we wanted
to get the investor community home photo
with the pricing and and the malls I put
together an Excel mall it was passed to
everybody and then people started to
plug with this thing but in order to
feel comfortable they had to have the
data so that's the one I show you want
to update the values from now to from
then to now you have to call France or
you know maybe somebody in Bloomberg can
give you the data I don't know it's not
public information yes
yes yes definitely for example what we
all know in the US is exposed to
hurricanes in Florida earthquake
earthquakes in California china has a
lot of earthquake risk India the same
Japan Italy has a lot of volcano I
remember pitch into the Ministry of
Finance of Italy a volcano bond and you
know it didn't get done but it was very
interesting to develop an index just for
volcanoes they halibel came in the
southern part of Italy de every time
there is a little bit of activity the
whole economy of the southern part of
Italy does it you know goes crazy and
nothing happens so just a bunch of smoke
but one day something is gonna happen
and Italian research don't want to take
the risk so it's perfect for a cat bond
and all of these may he co did my deal
the deal i'll show you for a subtler was
actually don't with the government of
Mexico they they do the right thing and
all of these guys have heard the story
but I haven't done anything no that's a
good question so one of the things I'm
doing trick is you go and check out my
website tweak is what you're going to
see is that the firm that we were
showing only is a light consumer
business to consumer thing you know but
we have a lot of b2b stuff and we're
pricing all kind of exotic risk all kind
of exotic risk using these soft
techniques and some others but yeah I
have done this for film I have done this
for music royalties I have done this for
I'm using now for for social data and
neither is a lot of value there any
other question Jim Jamie came from
karting excellent yes
well you know we have been approached by
some group to do that and it's
fascinating because you know in mind
that you are let's say JP Morgan right
and then you have let's say your
platinum clients or whatever let's say
that the guys the guys that the bankers
are measuring all the things that they
can measure and they can hedge you know
currency risk interest rate whatever for
this service degrees nobody's really
integrating them as part of a you know
enterprise-wide risk management system
so what happened if an earthquake hits
one of the facilities of your biggest
client how does put it down to you how
does it affect the you know supply the
chain of supply of products and services
and all that nobody's doing that so this
is on some other thing we're starting to
explore in my company in the private
side you're not going to find any of
this in what you look you're going to
find social search and semantics are
changing and some deal thing but these
are things are just starting you know
our dear just starting they have a lot
of potential any other question yes
yes yes mm-hmm yes yes basically if you
look at it it's just data Prague's you
know all of this is data you're not
dealing really with any physical asset
it's just mathematical models sadistic
on walls and a lot of data and then you
can put value on assign probability to
these and compared to real risks like
call it real you know so one of the
fascinating thing with these type of
bones it's like a crash in the stock
market can cause a default of a
corporate bond just because of
correlations you know you can drag a big
thing in the stock market can drag a
bunch of corporate bonds we saw that in
2008 but they cannot cause an earthquake
right and so that's fascinating because
the money is isolated from any event
it's an remote and a bankruptcy entity
thing an SPV and you can have a
financial meltdown but none of that is
going to cause an earthquake or
hurricane so it's a good thing to have
in a portfolio yes
that's right so nobody really knows if /
to the chart you see that the spread is
there so the spread is usually because
it's perceive us riskier but it's a
fascinating classic class by itself you
know the risk mathematically speaking
are the same as a corporate bond
defaulting but the spreads are a lot
nicer for a cat bond so it's a different
asset class it's a very good point i
think that is Harvey trash there i think
the spray is a better indicator the
rating is just they had to create a new
there was a very interesting case you
when i was a banker i was trying to
pitch this bone to CD or managers you
know usually the buyers of these bonds
are insurance companies because they
understand this stuff you know so you're
uninsured in germany and you want
exposure to earthquake in the u.s.
because you already have exposure to air
question germany well it's not that easy
to come on right insurance or equity in
the u.s. because there are regulatory
issues right so a good way to get
exposure is to buy disorder bonds you by
an earthquake one and you have exposure
to earthquake risk in another
jurisdiction and now it's cray but while
the market was just a bunch of insurance
companies buying each other's risks it
wasn't going to grow so one of the
things I was pushing is have countries
issue this sort of bone instead of
insurers and it was done so first thing
accomplished have a country issue one of
those second thing have older people buy
this bald man just insurance companies
in order to have always behind insurance
so in order to have all the type of
buyers buy these bonds I have to talk to
rating agencies because you know what
the rating agency said this is insurance
so if you put it in an insurance if you
put in a portfolio it counts as a bone
from the insurance industry so I don't
give you any crazy for diversification
so you have to the case mathematically
I've talked to them and these people are
reasonable is you show them
mathematically guys this is a totally
different risk it should have its own
different class so we did that and so
they say okay you're right is a
different type of risk so I give you
credit for diversification but it's just
fighting with regulators and you have to
have them all back in your you know
point thank you